today i want to have some fun on
archicad 24 and show you guys exactly
how to design a magnitude of different
elevations
so quickly and so easily
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about elevation
design in archicad 24.
we're simply going to go through a
couple different options where we can
manipulate and change the front
elevation
very very rapidly without having to
change and manipulate the rest of the
house
so if that's something that interests
you there's a subscribe button down
below there's a like button down below
i'd appreciate it if you smashed both of
them
and down below all of that is a couple
of descriptive links as well
which you might be interested in one in
particular is going to be the download
link
to this archicad file that we're working
on today
it's available through the patreon
discord link so if you check out that
link down below
you will be able to access everything
that i've done today anyway enough of my
rambling let's turn around to these
screens and get into the tutorial
alright so because i am located in
australia i have the australian
select template available to me if you
guys have
your american template or whatever
template you have available just use
that one
we're not using anything fancy it's just
the basic template that comes with
archicad 24.
once we have archive24 open and ready to
go we're going to start this video like
we start every single other one
control 7 opens up our story settings
it's important for me to set up story
settings first because it just makes
life a hell of a lot easier
when you're working on this project
later on down the track
so i start with inserting one below and
calling it footings
and it is minus 172 for me
in particular i put 172 because that's
the size of a slab and a bit of footings
in general so we don't really have to
worry too much i'm going to go to the
ground floor plan i'm going to change
that to 200
2745 which is a timber frame
size i'm also going to change the first
floor to
ground ceiling which i'm going to make
about
250 millimeters
i'm going to change the roof to first
floor
i'm again going to make that 2745
and i'm going to insert one more calling
it the
first ceiling or the roof again at this
point in time i'm gonna make it about
250 mil
it's probably going to be about 600
depending on the elevation design we end
up going with
but let's untick all of these click ok
and we're going to see they all open up
on this settings
side over here going into the ground
floor plan we're going to start by
creating the most
basic outline of the house that you can
think of we're not going to do anything
fancy it's literally going to be
just a couple walls and we're going to
see how we can manipulate this
and change it to a whole bunch of
different variations so let's start with
the wall tool
changing the wall layer making sure it's
on
external that's always important for us
and we're going to change the actual
type of wall itself
so if i scroll down to sp03 90
millimeter stud partition
it's just a timber stud wall or a steel
frame wall at 90 mil it's probably going
to be
timber but it's generic at this point in
time it doesn't really matter
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
draw a very very long line let's say we
have a very long
elongated block at 25 meters long
now to achieve this all i've done is
click once with my wall
hold shift press the d button and
type in 25 000 millimeters i'll go back
another 6 000 millimeters and repeat the
process
until i create one entire square so i've
got my
bottom ground floor of what we're really
going to see from the street
we're not worrying about the rest of the
house it's just that front elevation
that we can see
so we're just going to see what we can
come up with as we progress throughout
this video if i go to the first floor
double click and then i'm going to right
click on ground floor
and simply select show as trace
reference so we're gonna see that the
trace reference appears
as a ghost layer underneath we can
change the color as we like so if we
don't like the color that we see we can
make a green
blue red purple whatever you really like
and what however you feel
works best for you by holding the alt or
option key
we can actually replicate the wall
underneath so i hold alt
and i click once and all of a sudden i
can start drawing new walls so i'll
click escape because i don't want to
draw those walls
i'm thinking of creating some sort of
long elongated building
so let's click over here let's go all
the way across
let's cantilever it let's say cantilever
3 meters for this
we'll run that another six meters wide
holding shift we make sure it's straight
clicking once clicking twice we finish
off
that final wall system there so now we
have show all in 3d at the top we can
right click we can go show all in 3d
we can select this marquee tool and as
long as this
black selection or the dark outline
selection is shown
clicking once clicking twice right click
show only selection in 3d means we can
actually control what we want to see
so as you can see we've already started
to create this elongated shape at the
bottom where we can probably put a
double garage and entry
up the top we have our master bedrooms
and whatever the floor plan might
actually end up being
so right now i can envision this as
about two or three different options
very very
very quickly if i wanted to spend a lot
more time on it you could probably come
up with 20 or 30 different elevations
on this very simple structure here
so for me personally i'd probably start
by just defining a few spaces
i think over here will be our garage and
our carport
or whatever we have potentially just a
sliding gate
over here we might have some bedrooms
they might not need any windows at the
front they might all be
interior facing courtyard windows it
might be a villa style project that
we're looking at
so let's say we have the freedom of
flexibility to put windows at the front
to not put windows at the front it
really gives us a lot more diversity
if it isn't all glazing so let's jump
back to the ground floor
and define where we believe our
carport should be so simply collecting
the fill tool over here
it doesn't really matter what settings
or anything because we're going to
delete it in a minute
all i want to do is click once select
the
geometric method and press the d
button go tab my way through these
dimensions
go 000 by 6000 gives us
roughly our garage area so by clicking
on this shape once clicking control d
and clicking that again i'm able to move
it how i see fit
i'm just going to move it in line with
this wall here
and i'm going to right click that first
floor go show as trace reference so we
have quite a large amount of
area in between our garage and our
floating
top floor i think personally i'm just
going to drag this in a little bit
at the moment all my walls are grouped
i'm going to hit alt
g ungroup them and i'm able to select
one wall individually so clicking once
i'm going to be able to select both of
these click once click again
and then ctrl d to move it in as i
really want to
so i'm probably going to move it all the
way across control d again
and hitting the d button allows me to
bring it back
1500 i'm just going to push it 1500 back
so i can create some sort of entry
weight here
some way to get into the house so
let's get rid of that holding control
allows you to get the scissor tool out
clicking once just deletes that wall we
don't see it anymore
it's perfect it's done now i'm going to
introduce a sliding gate here
and i'm probably going to replace most
this wall with some sort of timber
screen
maybe we do a garden internally
underneath so it's all seen from the
street
maybe we manipulate it with some walls
and windows let's see how we go
so we start by simply going into the
door tool
clicking on the door we have a bunch of
standard doors but all i'm looking for
in this instance
is a sliding door so now we have an
exterior sliding door available from the
default archicad 24 settings i'm going
to change the grids to a hv grid which
allows me to manipulate it to see how i
see fit
i'm then also going to click on this
icon here which gives me an elevation
view
of what i'm looking at personally as you
probably know by watching these videos i
hate seeing the orange color
it's just a template thing but we can
open up this floor plan and
section detail click override pen and
change our pen to black so it isn't an
ugly yellow
coming back into the sliding door
details we can
click through once and start
manipulating these settings here so i'm
thinking it's going to be a sliding gate
for that garage or carport more so
and it's just going to be a timber
vertical screen the simplest way i can
do that
is by removing this vertical element to
one
and making this six meters
wide so let's make that six meters wide
now we have a beautiful wide garage door
we're going to make it two
four height so there's plenty of room
for all sorts of cars to clear it we're
going to introduce
a 35 millimeter thick bar
and on both width and thickness
it's going to go all the way through the
leaf and we're just going to tap to see
how many of those we need
so 20 probably isn't enough 40 is
probably just the right amount
if we go to 45 it might be a little bit
too much it might not we'll see when we
actually
put it into the project and then what
we're going to do is go to model
attributes and we're going to start
changing a few bits and pieces here so
to make this a perforated screen we have
to
kind of manipulate it a little bit so
let's start by overriding the settings
here i'm fine with it all being pine
wood grain because
i'm going to change it in twin motion
later down the track anyway
and i'm going to change this glass
leaf to air so changing those settings
straight to air
clicking okay and introducing our
sliding door now if i click escape it's
open about 10 percent we can change that
in our settings if we want to
but it just shows that it's a sliding
door going back into our 3d
we'll see that the project's changed
quite a bit but we have this nice
3d sliding gate which has perforated
screens
now if we wanted to we could go back in
we could change that
so it had more vertical bars it could
have less it's completely up to you guys
design it however you wish door settings
just coming back into that leaf let's
say we want
520 that was definitely accidental but
it makes a solid panel door
now we go back into it let's change that
to
50 and again we're back to somewhere
where we started so now i'd probably
like
the rest of this entire wall to be a
similar vertical pattern
so if i come back into the ground floor
plan click
on that wall i've downloaded ci tools
covering it's an additional plug-in to
archicad but it is phenomenal and i
truly do recommend it
not sponsored if you know anybody from
arcade or ci tools that wants to sponsor
it
always happy for a chat but if we go
into this coverings tool
and jump across to wall coverings we
have a bunch of options that we can play
with so let's say we want to introduce
some boards and bats which gives us that
timber vertical screen we're going to
rotate it 90 degrees like we've seen
if i click it multiple times on this
picture it'll rotate it around so i can
see
what's going on i don't think i want 800
millimeter spacing on this b
setting so let's change that to 50
we'll make c 35 and then i'm going to
start messing with the rest of settings
so
that's currently what i have it at i'm
going to manipulate it a bit more see
what it looks like when it's finally
finished
i've also overwritten the settings here
so it matches that garage door
simply clicking ok and dragging it on
the outside of that wall
we're going to see it creates corners
but we're not really worried about that
yet we'll go into more detail later now
you can see we've created this
board and batten pattern which is
vertical very similar
to this sliding gate that we've created
but if i press the m tool for a
measuring tool
i can see we only have about an 80mm gap
between each of those boards so if i
open up these settings again by clicking
command t
control t whichever system you're on or
you can come to this settings dialog box
at the top
i'm going to drop that back down to
it's 80 between so let's call it 105
there i also don't want this top and
bottom bar
so i'm going to go all the way across
looking at my
square edges now we're in horizontal
trims i probably don't want to change it
to none
i'll probably just reduce it down to 35
so it finishes that trim really nicely
i'll do 35 there too and i'll do the
same
on my bottom of wall base so
35 35
now if i click ok we'll see that pattern
completely change
there we go we've started to align with
our garage sliding carport
we have this elevation here all natural
timber
and now we can start introducing some
windows and then start playing with it
small come back to our ground floor plan
click on the window tool
let's just get one really nice long
skinny window
in here so if we go into window let's
just search window 24
we have window 24 there so just like the
sliding door i'm going to override those
settings because i hate that orange it
drives me crazy
and then i'm not really going to mess
with anything in here i'm going to do it
in 3d to see
how i like it the best so let's
introduce this small window here
and i'm going to drag it all the way
across
in line with the edge of that building
just for starters so coming back into 3d
we'll see we've introduced this
giant window which in reality i'm not
really sure what we'll be using this
house for
it would potentially be a massive living
room games room
i'm not entirely sure but it is quite a
stunning space
i'm going to reduce that to 600 mil what
i'm then going to do is go back to the
ground floor
plan and just center that perfectly in
between
this sliding gate and the edge of that
wall so by clicking on
that window once clicking control d
going all the way across
once coming back to the side repeating
that same step
ctrl d all the way across 3170 we'll
call it
so if i can do quick maths i think
that's approximately
1575. or thereabouts
don't judge me on my average math skills
um okay so now we have this beautiful
landscape window
centered across the whole building i'll
probably go into those settings again
command t
dropping down to the model attributes
and i'll just change that to
metal iron for now go okay so it gives
us
a black finish rather than just a simple
timber one
that's a very long piece of glass and as
beautiful as it is
it would be very challenging to actually
manufacture so
we'll go back up to the settings and
we'll probably introduce
a divider so we'll go hb grid again
we'll simply go uh one vertical
three a four horizontal is absolutely
fine we'll probably make them silicon
joints so 10 mil
10 mil and clicking okay
so now we have a more realistic window
that would actually be created
it'll be four separate panels of glass
instead of one giant panel glass
it's doable it's 100 doable it's just
super expensive so now we have the
foundation of our first elevation
if i go back into our ground floor plan
and click control
the down arrow we're going to go into
our footings layout as you can see it's
changed here
i'm going to go show us trace reference
for the ground floor
and i'm just quickly going to draw a
mesh in so
we have some sort of ground to work with
so site mesh you can see i've got it a
soil
it is a grass texture i'm then going to
click on the black dot on the edge
subtract the polygon
and make that about six meters wide
that gives us our driveway holding my
alt button again i can replicate that
clicking on our mesh command t
i'm just going to change that to
concrete doesn't really matter which
concrete i pick for the moment
so it's more or less just for the simple
purposes of
giving us an indication of what's going
on
i'm going to click command d while
having everything selected and move that
up 172 mil
so now we have the beginning of
what is going to be quite a nice home if
i scroll back up and go to ground
ceiling right click on ground floor plan
see where our actual floor plan is
of the above floor so what i'm going to
do is create the slab tool
get the square because it's a very
simple square zoom into the edge
click once zoom out zoom back into the
other edge
click another time and go back to our 3d
marquee as you can see i've created that
slab what i'll call it for the upper
floor
it is too low so there's a number of
ways to change it you can scroll across
increase that by 250 and then it is a
cantilevering
concrete slab i'm also going to just
change this
in all these settings here to concrete
as well
so i'll pick a different concrete than i
had before
it doesn't really matter to be honest
i'll pick 23 again
so now i have concrete 23 as my base
i'm also going to open that up once more
and just override
all those greens because again i hate
the colored lines
so there we go now we have the beginning
of our first
elevation it is very simple it's the
garage at the front it's a window at
there
and it's a cantilevering box basically
we're going to do a couple more things
to make this realistic
and to make it work so what i'll do is
i'll go back into
the ground floor ceiling plan i will
right click the ground floor plan go
show us trace holding the alt button
i'll draw
something inside here so that'll depict
our
roof internally i will then
reduce that back to zero like we
originally had so it hides and
disappears
if we're actually talking about this
from a construction point of view if
this is going to be a concrete roof
it would be a lot deeper than that that
concrete roof definitely
wouldn't have any value in being
anything like that
in a real world we'd probably push that
up about 600 and have a concealed roof
behind
with a one to two degree pitch instead
of having a concrete roof but we're
really just talking about elevations
and we're going to start doing some
different roof design in a minute too
so if we were to have just one concrete
roof behind here
one concrete slab over the edge here
and then a secondary roof over the top
just to finish off that design we'll go
to ground ceiling
we'll click on that once control c
first floor ceiling control v it'll ask
you center of current view or original
location we want original location
click ok and click off away from that
spinning dashed line we saw a second ago
coming back into 3d
now we see we have our building coming
together
i am going to change all of these walls
into some sort of concrete color for the
simple purpose
to make it all look exactly the same
so now we have a floating building over
the top
of our main building down below and we
basically have our first elevation now
the purpose of this is to be actually
able to create a different elevation
from this so let's say
this is where you started this is the
project you had the client came back to
you and goes
i don't like the elevation what can you
do for me well
elevations are quite simple and you can
mess around with them as much as you
like
to make them really work for you so what
i'm going to do
is come back to the ground floor plan
and then i'm going to use the marquee
tool
and clicking control l turning
all my layers on so all layers visible
okay marquee
that section right there so i have
absolutely everything that i've just
created
on all levels above and below if you
make sure you have
that selection at work otherwise all
your other marquees
will really just give you what you're
looking at so i'm going to click ctrl d
and control once more to replicate
and then i'm actually going to click
control and alt to be able to replicate
it multiple times
now i'm going to type in 60 000 which is
going to give us one
identical copy of that and now i'm going
to type in 120
000 to move that once more
further away so if we go back into our
3ds
we'll see if i zoom out a little bit and
right click
go show all in 3d because that is now my
new selection
you can see i have three copies of that
identical project so now we have this
first
basic kind of luxury but very
minimalistic
timber frame concrete look house and we
have our secondary house that looks
identical that we're going to completely
manipulate
and see what we can come up with so the
easiest way to give
elevation a different look is by simply
changing the roof lines
the roof lines can go from flat pitched
to mono pitch to ceiling to
i don't know hamptons to gables to all
sorts of ideas
very very very quickly so let's say
we are looking at a pitched roof design
potentially with a gable end
on this side here so let's just hit that
one
delete go to our roof ceiling
show our first floor as our trace
reference
going to our roof tool i'm going to make
sure i have single plane geometry
selected
and clicking once on this outside edge
holding shift to make sure it's straight
clicking on the inside edge where we
want the roof to go
centering it lining it up drawing my
first square to finish off my first
roof clicking on that roof section
control or command m mirrors it and then
control gives you a duplicate so holding
shift now we have a duplicate of that
there
as you can see my roof has already been
created quite quickly quite easily
and it's at a 22 degree pitch if i
wanted to change that make it 25
we have a weird church looking situation
here bringing that back down to 30
changes it once more
now all my walls are grouped i'm going
to simply click alt
g to ungroup them selecting just that
wall
clicking on one of these top nodes
clicking height adjust
and moving it up now if i select both
that wall
and the roof itself i can right click
connect trim
to roof shell trim and there we go
that's
gone beautiful disappeared what i think
we need now
is some sort of window to actually
emphasize the beauty of that roof
and how it has been designed what i'll
do is
click on both those go to ci tools
covering
roof covering again fantastic uh
tool that you can download off the
internet it is a little bit expensive
but it's definitely worth the price and
let's change this
to a corrugated roof for no other reason
than corrugated roofs are what australia
uses
most now because i'm not going into it
in this video i'm just going to change
these roof battens clicking on this user
defined
and moving that down to 90 just to hide
that from view so we don't see it
anymore
it's a bit ugly anyway so we don't
really want to see it
in a different video i actually talked
ab about how we can create a wraparound
black max line looking cladding which is
ultra modern ultra minimalistic and
sleek
i will quickly just duplicate those
settings
in this project here if you want to go
back and check out that video
i will link it down below link in this
video i'll do my best to remember
if not you're looking for a really
modern black gable end roof
thumbnail now remember everything that i
do in this video will be available
through the patreon discord link
so if you want to go ahead and check out
that link down below to be able to get
this file to be able to use it however
you see fit
which means you'll get access to these
ci tools a one-time use only you can't
really manipulate them change them
because you don't have
an id for them but you can see the tools
how they work
you can see the roof structure how i've
created it you can see the max line
cladding
and you can just generally play around
with the project itself
you can take it into twin motion you can
render it out again
it's basically your file to do whatever
you wish with it okay so what i've gone
ahead and done
is replicated that maxline cladding that
i was talking about in a previous
project hopefully i've linked it in this
video i will do my best to put a little
info card so you can check out how we
created this max line cladding
it is exactly the same process as we
created these boards down below
it's just a different series of settings
so if i open this
up and you give you these settings here
take quick screenshot it is exactly
those settings and you can create this
beautiful metal
cladding that wraps up into your secret
gutter roof
that roof is slightly different so if we
come back in
to the roof design and if you want to
screenshot this as well
you can match it perfectly like for like
so again screenshot that i'll leave it
there for a second
okay that's all the time you can go back
if you need to so now we have this
beautiful
pitched gable roof floating over our
bottom
timber floor i think we definitely need
a window on this
elevation like i said before so let's go
back into our first floor
you can see this roof shell i don't like
it so i'm just going to turn it off
because
it's too hard to see with it on so shell
tick okay let's just move that to that
actual
roof shell layer so it disappears
there we go now we can see our walls
again if i come into our window tool
go window we can use window 24 just like
we did before
centering it there we're going to start
creating our first window
so we're definitely going to want that
to be significantly bigger let's say
it's roughly 4 meters 300 wide
we're going to do the same thing we did
downstairs centering it clicking across
command d
finding the center 1700 half 1700
1850 and we have our first window
what we're also going to do is quickly
replicate that window by clicking on it
once
clicking control gives us a duplicate
going back into settings
and changing it to triangle window 24.
i'm not going to mess around with this
just yet
clicking ok very quickly very simply
dragging it across
to match our window and going back into
3d to see what kind of mess we've made
so we've got our triangle window down
the bottom clicking on that ctrl
d moving it all the way up now we have
our
pitched gable triangle window i still
don't like that that's probably
the wrong shape so i'm going to make
that a little bit bigger and i'm also
going to change the settings of this
triangle window so going into the
triangle window and just tapping through
these settings to see what we need to
change
most of it's pretty self-explanatory
most of it's pretty fine we will change
the actual color let's change that to
paint
black black glass is fine
model attributes reveal all of that is
pretty much okay
and then simply clicking ok what we do
want to change is the height to try and
match our
gable roof now i usually use 4d library
so you can match it a little bit better
a little bit easier so i'm just going to
manually go through this to try and
figure out where we need to be
so 1400 by 43 is pretty bang on
i'm going to drag it that little bit
higher up so let's say it sits at 2
6 and then i'm going to connect
this window to the triangle window as
well
okay so we have our window dragged up
i'm going to go into these settings
and just simply make it black like we
did to the last one
all simple done i'm going to add a hv
grid to this one as well
because it just doesn't look
aesthetically pleasing as one
giant panel so horizontal one
horizontal two vertical one in this case
and
we're going to make it a hundred by a
hundred let's make it a big chunky thick
one
clicking okay we're gonna do the same
thing for this triangle window up the
top
so same way going into sash options
grid hb grid two one
one two sorry my mistake 100
100 okay there we go
ah one more error going into those
settings going
back to our model attributes we can see
that
all of these didn't change automatically
like they do on most windows
so we'll just quickly change them and
there we go
we have our second elevation done
rapidly now more than likely you
wouldn't keep a flat roof down below
because it's just too expensive so what
it actually do
is now create a secondary roof here so
let's cut that off
let's go to ground ceiling we're going
to
activate our roof and right click ground
floor
show as trace reference same way we did
with the upper floor
except we're stopping in line with
the floor above we know exactly where it
is because we have that
slab on that same floor i don't know
where the center is perfect with this
one but that's okay
so i finished it early clicking on this
once clicking control
m and then clicking control allows us to
hold shift
click a couple times and replicate that
so if i was to drag it all the way to
the edge of this wall
i can now hold ctrl whilst one of these
roofs are selected
click on the other one and do the same
to automatically
merge them to where they need to be now
what i can do is click on both
control d control again to duplicate
and clicking on one of the edges to
offset that
all the way across now we have our
chunky thick roof again
that doesn't really work with what we're
looking for so i'm going to
hold alt and hold alt and control
to replicate those settings
for the roof there at the end now again
we can drag up
these walls click the two roof and
connect if we need to depends
on the elevation we're really messing
with so it can be seen it can be not
seen
it doesn't really matter too much just
depends how you want to go about it
now there are actually timber roofs out
there that you can create and you can
use
they are super expensive hard to come by
not many people use them because
they're a bit of a maintenance issue
they're a bit of fire issue there's all
sorts of problems and dilemmas with it
but it's a render it's an elevation
design so what i'm actually going to do
is select all of these go to my roof
coverings
and actually use this one here to
replicate what we did below
if i change the settings something to
like this clicking okay
we might get pretty close we might not
i'm not 100 certain
but we do get a timber looking
ribbed roof now that isn't perfect it's
not exactly what it should be i'll also
select
these two rooms here change them to wood
and click ok so they disappear a bit
better
we're not going into the details of how
we actually model a timber roof in this
video i'll go into that another video
down the track
but there's our second elevation done
very rapidly
so as you can see if i scroll out zoom
out we have this very
kind of boring box i guess if you want
to call it
and then we have our more kind of barn
looking elevation
again nothing fancy nothing amazing but
let's spend a little bit more time on
this next elevation
to try to get a little bit more quirky
with it so we still have our third
elevation which is a replica of our
first
over on this side here now personally
i've got a million and one ideas of how
we can create this to make it something
interesting to make it something
powerful
to make it something amazing we could
spend hours on this third elevation
but we probably won't spend that long so
i'll try get
the fundamental ideas out as quickly as
possible
to really try and manipulate this form
so
we can create something quite special so
if this was going to be a multi-million
dollar house it would have landscaped
gardens it would have a beautiful
driveway it wouldn't just be
grass and concrete there would be a lot
more detail in it
if you do actually download this pln
file most likely i would have done that
to create the thumbnail for this photo
so you'll get the bonus added extra
grass
details here but if we're going to
create some sort of luxury architectural
home
there'd be some strong concrete elements
into this design
there'd be a lot more architectural
windows happening there would be
cantilevered awnings there would be
boxed out windows
there would just be a lot more detail so
let's start with the ground floor plan
and introduce a few more elements into
this garage
so let's go ground ceiling and move
across to our third
item in question i want to actually
extend
this concrete roof here so what i'm
going to do
is make that 66 by
500 then i'm going to create a 250 by
500
section on this side here as well so if
we go back into 3d
you'll see i've created two multiples of
that and then i'm going to
increase the thickness all the way to
the ground so now we have
some sort of concrete awning around this
roof i'm going to make it a lot deeper
let's make it another 500
let's do the same for this side here so
we're just clicking on the blue square
extending it we have our first concrete
box around the side
um it gives us some sort of indication
that this is our entry portal that's
where we're going to
i'll probably actually duplicate that on
this side
so i'm going to run through this very
quickly like i said before i'm not
really going to go into too much detail
of how i do everything you're just going
to see more of my workflow and
architectural process
if we go to the first floor now i'm
going to introduce a corner window
right here so i'm going to go to my
windows
window window 24 is absolutely fine as
you know we can
mess with it we can play with it so
let's extend that to that large go to
the settings change our corner settings
clicking ok on a custom 90 corner
mirroring that because it's the wrong
way around
lining it up duplicating it and
extending it a little bit further so
we've come back into 3d
we have this very large window here i
don't like how long it is i'm going to
make it about that
and about there so it's very linear very
narrow
we're going to center it somewhere about
here
and then i'm just going to simply change
the colors to black there we go we have
a nice skinny black window
around that side what i'm going to do is
go back into the first floor plan
click on my slab tool and simply draw
a 300 millimeter box around it
so bear with me because this will all
make sense in a second
i'm only going to make that 10
millimeters thick and
going into our floor 3d you'll see that
i've created a slab
i'm going to drag that up there i'm
going to drag that up there boxing it
out
giving it that architectural profile
making it black
same as the window there and then very
similar to how
we just created that edge for the garage
we're going to create a secondary edge
right here for this boxed out window
frame so there we go i've now just
duplicated this
beautiful black fin across i'm quite
liking that so
as we progress i'll group all of these
items together
move them up let's move one here and i'm
going to duplicate a second one here
so now we have two of these black razor
sharp fins coming off the side of this
building
which looks really really nice i'm not
liking this in a concrete look so i'm
gonna change that
let's change it to some sort of white
texture
so let's just paint it a white ish color
for now
i'm actually going to change that
cladding completely
to a black monument so i'm going to
steal
that max line cladding from the previous
project
clicking on that to duplicate it very
rapidly very quickly
changing that gate color as well now we
have our black sliding gate with our
contrasting
white awning i don't think i need that
side at all i don't like that i don't
love it at all
i'm going to extend this to see how this
quickly looks all the way across there
and i'm going to line it up with the
edge of this window just
so we have something to line it up to
cantilevering now we have this
linear line all the way through what i'm
going to do
is introduce the secondary elements so
duplicating this edge
near the window dropping it down
significantly
to the top of that window and
replicating our
top feature dragging that back to the
edge of the other window
so now we're just talking about vertical
linear lines we probably don't need that
to go that far let's bring it
back we have some sort of architectural
feature in there we desperately need
some sort of front door in here that's
just clearly obvious so let's go back to
our ground floor plan
doors external door door 24
we'll probably just make that a h door
as well
we'll probably just make no grid doesn't
really matter
just yet we'll see how it looks and how
we
interpret it once we put it into our 3d
model if you can't already tell i design
very much so in 3d i like to see it i
like to visualize it
and then i progress as the design
progresses
so there we go we have this perfect
space for that door
right there it's a little bit small i'm
going to increase the size of that to
the same size the garage
which means it becomes 2 4 high and sits
just under
our nice architectural wrap around
features here
so this would probably be some sort of
precast paneling with a proper concrete
roof on the top
so if this were a proper concrete roof
and we really were getting
into the nitty-gritty of it we'd have
some sort of beautiful garden on top of
here and another one on top
so let's quickly create that going into
our ceiling
i'm going to use any old wall i'm going
to make it 500 tall
i'm going to offset it a little bit i'm
not really too worried about what i'm
offsetting
so there we go we have that one
we have this one if i select all them
duplicate them quickly
drag them in there slice them in half
get rid of those get rid of those delete
those go back to my 3d
we'll see we have this little concrete
plinth that's created above
so going into our mesh tool and just
simply drawing a little bit of earth in
there
if i drag that up and let's just change
that to
just the stone granite gray duplicating
that on that side and let's just drop
that 50 mil
so in reality what it would be would be
a flat concrete roof a little bit of an
upstand on this side
and then there'll be petals
waterproofing all sorts of different
layers
to be able to actually get that concrete
roof working which means you can utilize
that
as a beautiful green space it means the
plants and flowers can overlap the house
if you want them to
very common in humid climates very
common in general with the concrete roof
we'll actually replicate the same thing
on our ceiling
now the higher up you get if you're
standing on the ground and looking up at
the building
you probably would only see this one
here
you wouldn't see the top one but it
depends how you designed it if you
wanted those plants to cascade down or
not
it really up to you any way shape or
form
but generically that is the third
alternative elevation design
we can manufacture from a very simple
basic
design it is literally two boxes stacked
on top of each other
it is nothing special whatsoever
but it just shows us the freedom and
luxury that we have by introducing
different architectural elements so we
can change our style of windows we can
introduce window boxes we can change our
roof pictures we can introduce concrete
roofs and design them properly
we can introduce box outs around our
windows that
actually create sun shading we can then
manipulate the colors the scheme we're
introducing new doors new openings
we actually have so much possibility to
change
one design into a million different ones
that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you leave a comment
down below let me know what you liked
what you didn't like how i can improve
these videos
or simply just what you want to see in
the future
if you wouldn't also mind hitting the
subscribe button and also the like
button to help
this channel grow as it's been growing
tremendously well by you guys supporting
the channel over the past couple of
months
there's nothing further from me so like
always i will see you
next monday